let's go to katie in waco texas we've
been having
issues uh i we
in marriage um
with my husband late as of late is
treated
you know depression issues that i have
occasionally as an issue of frustration
and seems to be quite the burden
on him and i don't really know how to
handle it and go about it when that's
kind of just feeds
into the depression
are you depressed
yeah um yes sir uh
i have an issue and this is not
something brand new to me
or even in our relationship it
comes and goes and sometimes we have
harder times sometimes i have better
times sure you know
how long have you been married um
we have been officially married
for just over a year okay we
uh we've lived together for almost
three years i'm 27 he is 30.
okay so i don't i want to talk just
about you for a little bit okay
um how long have you struggled
how long have you been depressing how
long have you
been struggling with depression i
i mean off and on
throughout pretty much my life through
seasons
or issues or okay kind of whatever's
going on i mean you want to get it
way way back i was in sixth grade
complaining of stomach ache so
frequently my mom took me to the doctor
and the doctor told her to take me to
therapy
okay so for for most people
most of the time depression
anxiety that's your body's way of trying
to
protect it and it doesn't always feel
like it's helpful
but your body's doing the best it can to
protect you
so what what is your
body still trying to protect you from
what in your past does it not want to
deal with what relationships are
broken it sounds like from since when
you were a kid
well yeah you know i grew up in one of
those homes
um you know my parents divorced when i
was young
my dad was an alcoholic my mom heart
would
rarely would have touched a drink so
but you grew up in a disconnected house
with disconnected folks
and they doesn't mean they didn't love
you that didn't mean they didn't try but
um you were launched out
right and your body's been doing the
best it can to protect you for a long
long time
right yes sir and a lot of that
protection i'm just gonna guess here
has something to do with some sort of
withdrawing whether it's somatic pains
which is
nerd speak for your stomach hurts your
foot hurts your head hurts your back
hurts
what or whether that is
disconnecting from relationships from
pulling back right from
withdrawing am i on the right right
right track here yeah
yeah so um
a little context here we do have um
there are four little boys in our house
what ages are they so um
our new one is uh
four almost four months old and i've got
a
four five and seven four
five and seven in four months
yes how many of those are biologically
yours
they're all mine the new one
is biologically hit the other three are
not his but
no but he's so graciously and i mean he
is a good
man he is a very good man i am not going
to say he's like
a terribly horrible person by any means
so i'm going to reframe your husband for
you for a minute okay and i may be way
off and
people accuse me of being too optimistic
sometimes
but that guy loves you
do you agree with that yeah
does he love you a lot
i'd like to think so okay no don't don't
do that does he love you a lot
yeah okay i think he does he took on
three of your kids
he has dated you for several years he
married you he loves you
and there is nothing more painful
in the world than watching somebody you
love
hurt and when you have
a depressive episode when your body for
whatever is coming on in your
environment whether it's you've got a
four-month-old for god sakes
or four kids seven and age under in the
middle of a pandemic
in the middle of a wacky city that's
growing but not growing and kind of
growing there in waco
in the middle of a state that doesn't
know what what
what day it is sometimes right all of
those things
happening at the same time and then some
and then some right and historical
trauma that your body is still wrestling
with
and your husband looks at the woman he
loves more than anybody else in the
world
and sees her hurting and it's hard to
watch
and some guys and by some i mean almost
all of us myself included don't always
have the right tools to know what to do
when i can't run out and just strangle
it or i can't run out and write a mean
letter to it
to solve it right i can't go out and
have a stern conversation with or
whatever
we were trained to do and so sometimes
that frustration
that feels like a burden is simply a
powerlessness
that your husband has over the the pain
the woman he loves is feeling yeah right
and so i'm gonna put him to the side i'm
gonna assume he's a good guy trying to
figure out what he can
do how he can help and yeah he's
frustrated and yeah he's got
xyz and he's not going to say the right
things all those things right of course
the question i want to ask you is do you
want to be done with depression
well yeah who doesn't well
so but it comes with a cost
and that's why i'm asking and it may not
be a conversation that you can complete
on this call because it's going to be a
more long-term thing
but if you want to be done at some point
you have to go back to that six-year-old
little girl
whose dad didn't show up because he was
drunk again
whose mom wouldn't touch a drink she did
all the right things but
was trying to protect you and if you
have any siblings from
an alcoholic dad a six-year-old who's
still trying to figure out what she did
to make her parents split up
and you're gonna have to let that little
girl go play
you're gonna have to let her off the
hook because she's still trying to
protect you now
and as you have four kids
three by somebody else or more than one
other person
you are starting to the cycle is
starting to repeat itself
and then in instep's this guy that loves
you
and that's when i ask you this that's
the stage i'm setting to ask you this
question do you want to be done with it
because if you want to be done with it
it's going to take
some hard work on your part and it means
you're going to have to connect with
people in a way that you probably don't
have the skills to connect
and you're going to have to say the same
as you like i had i want to learn
spanish
i want to learn how to knit i'm going to
learn how to
connect with other people because i did
not get that skill growing up and i'm
not going to do that to my four kids
yeah i do not need better
no no they don't need better they need
you
yeah they need their mama because i know
you love those kids too don't you
yes sir a lot very very much
all right so here i want you to paint me
a picture
real quick what is a life free of
depression what does that
look like for you
i understand the question
totally what is it i mean what does it
look like
peace yeah there you go i guess yeah
i'll paint you some pictures okay i'll
put some things out there
you got four knuckle-headed little boys
and your
body feels good enough that you can roll
around on the floor of them and have a
big dog pile wrestling match every
afternoon
and you cannot react loudly you cannot
react through yelling or screaming or
withdrawing when one of them acts like a
five-year-old or a seven-year-old or a
four-year-old
and that you and your husband can have a
budget meeting together you can have
a hey we're not having enough sex
conversation together and you can have
it in a way that's not a fight but just
more of a hey
i need you to lean in on this area more
and i need to lean on that area more
or hey you've been working a lot of
hours i'd love just to have some time
with you
i'm sleepy and i'm just gonna go to
sleep with no meds
right i'm gonna take time to read a book
this i'm gonna do something that's not a
netflix special i'm gonna go for a walk
out there by the river there in waco
that's what i'm talking about not that
you're not gonna have sad days and
frustrated days and angry days
but the word you gave me is peace and
here's the thing if you learn
how to not be depressed what you can do
you're not gonna be healed you're gonna
be empty you're gonna have to
learn some new skills and if you go into
this that way
if you lean into learning new skills
giving yourself permission to fall down
and be graceful let your husband know
tell him to give me a call too okay
but i want you to hear me say this katie
those four little boys deserve this
that knuckleheaded husband of yours
deserves this and more than
anybody you deserve to let that little
girl go play
and you deserve peace
thank you do you believe me yes
okay so here's the deal i'm holding you
accountable to this
in 30 days i'm gonna email you back
i'm gonna email you back and i'm gonna
find out if you've gone to
see a counselor there in waco i'm gonna
find out if you and your husband have
sat down and had a conversation about
what does it look what does healing look
like what are some things he can do
not to give you advice not to get
frustrated but to start helping
in the in the house helping around the
house what are some
little wins what are some things you can
start doing i'm going to commit to
taking a walk
every day i'm going to take my kids out
for a walk we're just going to go walk
around the neighborhood i'm going to
commit because i'm going to be a steward
of my body
and be a steward of my mind i'm going to
be a steward of fill in the blank
i'm going to go back and watch all these
videos on youtube of
this show i'm going to really go down
the rabbit hole i'm going to
read or get audio books i'm going to do
the things i'm going to begin to learn
some of this stuff
and then the hard stuff i'm going to
start practicing it so i'm going to
email i'm going to put a note on my
calendar kitty i'm going to email you
in a month i'm going to check in on you
see how you're doing
i want you to be honest with me but i
believe in you and i believe that this
is the season that that cycle is going
to get broken
because you're going to choose i don't
want to be depressed anymore i don't
want to live in that life
i want to be peaceful
i want to be somebody of peace i'm so
glad that you call kitty
and um tell that husband look your
husband in the eye and say hey
i know you're frustrated but i talked to
a guy on the radio he told me it's just
because you love me
and i'm hurting and you don't know what
to do
and so then give him a big hug and then
just give him a big smooch
just tell him i love you that's not
going to help a lot but that'll be fun
for me